he's the great Clayton Kershaw the
Dodgers pitcher joining us on the
program good morning Clayton how are you
what are you doing all day I was feeding
babies is that is that Cooper
yes he's four months now and yeah man
we're doing good we're just kind of
hanging you know try and do a little
school with the older two and I'm kind
of working out and throwing when I can
and then it's really about it give him a
little airtime here let me let me see
it's nice yeah
left-handed right-handed do we know yes
tough to tell we'll see he's uh he's
been a good kid he's a third kid so he
knows you know what and you know this
after the first one you take all the
precautions you do all the right things
and then the second one you ease off a
little bit by the time you get to the
third and when we got to our fourth
we're like whatever that pacifier falls
out how long was it on the floor a stick
it back in your mouth you're good all
right so who do you work out with at
home I feel like I'll be ready
you know whenever this thing gets going
if it does I feel like they'll be a good
spot so it's uh you know it sounds
optimistic right everybody seems to keep
talking about it like it might happen so
that's exciting how long do you need to
get ready if I said this is that do need
to know the date for the start of the
season for you to then go through your
routine to get ready for the start of a
season I mean that would be nice you
know but I think they're proposing like
a 30 man roster potentially so that you
don't have to build up quite as much
when that happens you know you only need
four or five innings really to start the
season if you have thirty guys on board
and then yeah and so I mean with extra
30 guys I mean you probably only need
two or three weeks to be my guest but
how much are you how much contact are
you having with whether it's manager
with Dave Roberts or the Players
Association like who is your voice here
to help you understand what's going on
yeah I mean I talked with Doc you know
nobody really knows we're all just kind
of in a holding pattern as far as you
know what the season might look like
just because you know everything changes
week to week month to month with what's
going on right now so nobody really
knows for sure you know obviously the
MLB just sent over that proposal that
we're looking over I think right now I'm
having to talk about it soon but nobody
really knows you know know what's gonna
look like yeah what did you make a Blake
Snell's comment I hope you gave caving
to your wife I know I think it's
probably a little bold and what he said
but you know I think what where he's
coming from we've already made a paid
concession you know we're gonna get paid
prorated based on the season so we play
81 games where they get half our pay we
agreed to that already and I know guys
kind of felt like that was what we
decided you know as a union and
obviously with no fans changes things I
guess for some owners but we're still
playing the same game you know we're
still playing baseball
we still agreed to our salaries based on
that so all I can say about everything
is if it deems medically that we're able
to play and we can't figure out the
business side of it between the two
sides it's not gonna look good on
anybody so if we do figure out medically
I'm pretty optimistic that we can play
well how concerned are you about that
with your health I mean the
conversations you have with your wife
yeah I mean it's uh there's obviously
risk involved anytime but there's also
risk just going outside any day and
there's a lot of people smarter than me
thankfully figuring this stuff out as
far as what is protocol for what's going
forward and how to do this baseball
stuff and bottom line is I think the
majority of us want to play you know we
want to play and we want to be out there
and for whatever small that it is it's
probably helpful to the country to see
some sports I know I'm tired of watching
PGA golf reruns over and over again so I
think you
we want to do it and if somebody smarter
than us says that we can do it I think
you know I'd be on board for sure and
listening to Blake Snell and I said if
if you really are worried about your
health and you don't want to play this
year you're not gonna get paid and
that's your stance then that's fine I
applaud you I mean it's everybody's
individual choice here
the tricky part though Clayton is what
if the medical community says it's safe
the Players Association deems it safe
the Commissioner deems it safe and you
still don't want to go back what happens
to that player or those players who say
we still don't want to go back yeah I
think it'll still be their choice I
don't think that's gonna be I might be
naive in this but I don't feel like
that's gonna be the vast majority of
players you know you might have you
might have a few guys that have like
some serious health issues within the
family or some people that they just
can't take the chance of being around
and playing baseball and totally get
that but hopeful that the vast majority
of people can play and feel good about
it he's Clayton Kershaw the Dodgers
pitcher you got your hat on here
can you tell you you don't want to see
that oh yeah come on is it Bryce hardest
like yes is this Bryce Harper like I
think you just added about two inches to
your height here with that bad hat dog
that's great oh wait does your white cut
who cut your hair if I get desperate
great though you get to wear a hat to
work like you're an adult and you get to
wear a hat to work in oh my shorts and
t-shirts you got a baseball near you
yeah okay always okay is this an
important baseball you have there is
that like a memento of anything well I
got a ration this is a
new pearl I got a ration right now
playing catch because I only have so
many left I don't know how much longer
so I got to make sure this okay can you
show us some of the grips that you have
yeah okay now I remember Harold Reynolds
did something on baseball tonight and it
was on Johan Santana and he said this is
what hitters see the slot arm slot
delivery for a changeup and a fastball
looked exact and and he in Harold
Reynolds matched up to pictures he said
tell me which one's a fastball and which
one's a changeup now you know how
difficult it is when you're facing great
pitchers do you ever have pictures of
your arm slot that says that's my
changeup that's my fastball and then
make sure that they mirror each other
well not the change I don't know how
that's any good picture I think you know
they all kind of look the same coming
out of your hand and then they do
different things you know so I guess the
number one rule in pitching is to make
everything look as similar as possible
and then as long as possible and at the
end it moves differently so nothing
should change about your arm slot or
your arm angle or anything it's just the
the grip of the pitches and how you
release it alright so show me the
fastball the grip of the fastball all
right so I hold it like this with the
horseshoe on this side and a lot of guys
hold it like this with the I just did
with the horseshoe on this side but for
me I hold the horseshoe right there just
straight across four-seam fastball
I don't know how to throw it two-seam
fastball okay now if you're throwing
you're breaking ball
so curveball you take this seam right
here see it's hard to do it on zoom'
kind of and then middle finger right
there
and then a lot of guys do different
stuff with their index finger so I'm
spike it some point is straight up I
think Eric Gagne did it like this and a
lot of guys are doing this now and
that's but me I just throw a pretty
standard curveball and this one's just
kind of along for the ride all the
pressures right there the foam is the
thumb is on that seam and then just pull
down like hard as you can but but if I'm
looking at that I see your finger up
yeah aren't you tipping your that would
be you know yes I guess in theory but
that would be pretty tough to see I feel
like because your arms moving so fast at
that point by the time to come out of
your glove but I mean guys you know if
you're at second base you can see a
spike if you hold it in your glove the
wrong way and so guys get good tips that
way so you got to kind of cover it up
with your glove can you tell when
somebody at second base is telling
somebody at home plate what's coming you
know sometimes if they're really you
know if they're really bad at it but
most of the time no so if they say
breaking ball then then you know that
they're probably bad at it I would get
that can you throw a knuckleball no no
like one out of ten I can get it to do
something but I think they do it like
that
I think they kind of I think are like
alright Nikki I was like like he did
that I think and just kind of like
pushes it I'm so amazed with it I asked
Phil Phil Niekro about it and and he
shows you yeah night and then I I hate
playing catch with somebody who throws a
knuckleball because they think it's
funny that you're getting you know
hitting the knee or hitting the groin or
whatever and Charlie we have Charlie
Hough around still and Charlie Charlie
can still do it you can still just fire
but I I'm just fascinated though that
the difference in hell guys hold a
baseball and how how much pressure you
add to a baseball and how light it's
almost like a golf swing you know the
guy sometimes will grab it grip it too
tight can you can you grip it too light
or too strongly just I don't know I just
always I don't have a loose grip on
anything that's probably why I don't
throw a changeup very well but you know
what's funny is that you talk to guys
and like you know whoever has the best
of whatever you know you talked to
different guys about their changeups or
different guys about their sliders and
you want to see their grip because
you're like that's how they do it they
have a different it's the same grip
everybody has the same stuff it's just
it's just how their arm works how it
move how it comes out their hand like
the grip is almost irrelevant to some
extent and it's just over the years you
know you want to see how guys hold
different thing
but there's very few times that the grip
is just like oh that that's it that's
what changed my career you know did
anybody try to change your wind-up no I
mean I kind of had the same you know
over the years I think I've paused a
little bit more at the bottom but and
then you know I do that stupid thing out
of the stretch wait goes you acknowledge
it's stupid yeah now I just can't I
can't get rid of it it's like it's like
part of it now so I can't I can't not do
it
oh gosh well hey it's great to talk to
you hopefully we get some baseball
played and more importantly good luck
with Cooper there thanks guys appreciate
it Thank You Clayton that's Clayton
Kershaw Dodgers pitcher